[Music]
every day all over the planet millions
of people animals and products come and
go potentially traveling with them a
several known and unknown health threats
such as infectious diseases that can
cross over borders and continents and
endanger public health improving safety
security and protection for all citizens
against health threats our concerns at
the very heart of the European Union's
health policy recent outbreaks such as
the Ebola epidemic or the new emerging
Middle East respiratory syndrome
attesting the European Union's capacity
to respond quickly and efficiently to
these cross-border health threats in
2013 the European Parliament in the 28
member states agreed on a legal
framework on serious cross-border
threats to health call decision 1082
that provides mechanisms and tools to
manage health crises in the EU whilst
individual member states are responsible
for their own health measures decision
1082 supports cooperation and
coordination between member states in
order to fight against cross-border
health threats such as threats of
communicable diseases that can easily
spread from person to person and country
to country
[Music]
and the threat that certain bacteria are
becoming resistant to drugs and
medicines threats of bio toxins from
plants such as ricin that could be used
intentionally to harm people threats of
chemical origin that come from acute
releases of toxic chemical products or
threats caused by environmental events
such as a volcanoes ash clouds or
extreme weather events linked to climate
change decision 1082 encourages all
member states to better prepare for
future outbreaks by sharing their
information sharing their best practices
and ensuring that all their preparedness
plans are compatible consistent and
effective decision 1082 also allows
member states to be part of a new
venture in joint procurement to obtain
medical countermeasures such as vaccines
and medicines furthermore decision 1082
has established epidemiological
surveillance to constantly monitor over
40 communicable diseases across europe
and ad hoc monitoring when health
threats caused by chemical environmental
hazards or biotoxins occur
member states use the early warning and
response system ewr s to immediately
issue alert notifications to the
Commission to member states and to the
World Health Organization w-h-o about
the nature and the location of the
threat concerned in case of an outbreak
it is always vital to know what danger
exactly does the threat posed and what
are the risks for the people in the
European Union European agencies and
scientific committees will carry out
risk assessments of threats to suggest
options and appropriate measures that
can be taken by crisis managers during a
crisis the health security committee HSC
composed of representatives from all of
the 28 member states will consult each
other to coordinate measures to an
outbreak based on the risks involved the
health security committee also consults
on crisis communication to agree upon
messages that can be used by public
health authorities to ensure that both
the general public and healthcare
professionals are provided with clear
consistent coherent information
[Music]
eventually if required international
organizations such as the World Health
Organization will become involved and
international partners from other
countries will be consulted whenever
necessary supported by the Commission
decision 1082 gives us the mechanisms
and tools to manage public health crises
that help us to improve health security
in the European Union solid crisis
preparedness ultimately protects
Europeans against health threats and
prevents additional burdens on European
health systems we cannot anticipate
every disease and every threat but
together we can be prepared for the
worst and be ready to act quickly should
we have to deal with a crisis decision
1082 crisis management for serious
cross-border health threats in the
European Union
[Music]